[موسيقى]
لو نظرنا في التاريخ فان جل الخطوط في
العالم او كلها كانت مملوكه لشركات
الاتصالات لقد كان هناك دائما تعاون بين
الدول المختلفه وبين حكوماتها يمكنني
القول انه قبل ثمانيه او عشره اعوام
تقريبا بدات كل من جوجل
تنفقا على هذا الميدان ثم اطلقت جوجل
شبكتها التي تمكنها من الامتلاك الكامل
للخطوط وهذا يضعنا امام حاله احتكار تشمل
كل العالم غالبيه هذه الخطوط لا تملك
الشركات المحليه والحكوميه اي دوله فيها
حتى لو مرت عبر اراضيها وبحارها
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان الفابيت وميتا كانت ذكيتين جدا
في هذا الملف لان خطتهما تضمن لهما القبضه
على الكابلات بعد ان انشات غالبيه الخطوط
الحاليه فضلا عن خطتها الاستعراضيه
الكبيره في السماء وبعيدا عن المحيطات ما
يشعل اكثر القضيه لقد بلغت قبضه كلتيهم
على كابلات العالم في كل اجزاءه وانحاءه
حتى لو لم تكن لهما اجازه النشاط في
الدوله التي تمر بها الكابلات من وجهه نظر
قانونيه حتى وان كانت تبدوان محل نقاش الا
انهما عمليا هما من تقرران في هذا الميدان
وهما من تتحكمان بكيفيه اقوى من الحكومات
بحركه الانترنت
[موسيقى]